I haven't the faintest idea why I agreed
to this
I must be functioning copy prick can you
help us with this the Bernardo near the
bubble working sorry is this gonna work
hey dick Ababu a - a Nandita thank God
he's found something your droids
forbidden memory bank words translated
from sis that's it yeah that's what we
need
who are you hanging out with it speaks
sin can you make a triple Babu can you
make him translate it valedictory yes
but it will cause a complete mandate
memory what Lily we make him translate
if he won't remember anything good I
remember I go black oh there must be
some other way does an aren't you backup
your memory please our two storage units
are famously unreliable you know the
odds better than any of us do we have
choice
[Music]
if this mission fails it was all for
nothing or we've done all this time
we're doing there in Threepio
taking one last look sir
at my friends
[Music]
nitrates are gonna start soon I'll keep
lookout come on with you you still don't
trust me huh did you ever trust me nope
[Music]